Giants robots dragons Gods clowns I mean
literally no one is safe from being
taken down by Monkey D Luffy the hero of
One Piece has spent decades now punching
some of the most punchable faces ever to
appear in mang and Anime and today we're
talking about every single character
that Luffy has actually defeated
throughout the story and funnily enough
the very first thing that Luffy ever did
in the story when he set sail as a
pirate was punch the lights out of of
the lord of the coast and so he finally
got his revenge on the Sea King that
took shank's arm in the form of a
knuckle sandwich and in doing so he
finally proved he wasn't the same kid
that he used to be with this defeat
Luffy was ready to be a real pirate and
after a poorly timed waroo Luffy then
found himself barreling towards the
alvida Pirates literally after meeting
his most pink friend and future hero of
the Marines Kobe Luffy then set the
unwilling Cabin Boy free by punching his
boss the most beautiful pirate on the
Seas other than Bo hanok I guess right
well into the sea and after that Luffy
then ran into some opposition while
trying to recruit his very first
crewmate and actually a lot of fans
remember Luffy fighting xand Morgan
after freeing Zoro in Shell toown
however Zoro was actually the one to
finish the corrupt Captain off and so in
one of the biggest loive matchups of all
time Luffy actually defeats hel Meo
instead who was threatening Kobe with a
pistol and then immediately after that
battle Luffy then beat up Kobe in order
to give the Marines of shell toown the
impression that they aren't actually
friends after all what kind of real
friend would actually beat the snot out
of one of his best allies it's the kind
who wants you to live out your dreams
and then moving over to Orangetown Luffy
came face to face with the lion tamer
Moji and Richie the lion and while
Richie probably should have been caged
it was actually Luffy who found himself
locked in the cage instead on this
particular occasion however as a lot of
characters throughout one piece have
found out nobody can keep Luffy locked
up for long especially when he needs to
fight on behalf of Cho Chu one of
anime's best boys and on this occasion
Luffy couldn't just settle for simply
beating up Moji the lion tamer he also
needed to fight the boss and this was
Luffy's first fight against a fellow
devil fruit user making it a significant
challenge but once Luffy and Nami
managed to tie up all of Buggy's body
parts baby buggy didn't stand a chance
and got gumgum bazooka into the
stratosphere and so by the time that the
crew arrived in serup Village Luffy had
already taken out a lion so certified
catboy Captain Kuro didn't really stand
a chance there yes kuro's claws were
really sharp but Luffy's wits were
sharper okay that's maybe not 100%
accurate Luffy doesn't have any wits as
we all know his strategy was actually
just so dumb it actually ended up
working because he wrapped his rubbery
limbs all around Kudo so he couldn't use
his speed to his Advantage anymore and
gave him the headbutt to end all
headbutts in the form of a gugu bell and
since all that sort of Village business
really worked up an appetite Luffy and
the Gang next stop was the floating
restaurant the bartier and unfortunately
they weren't the only ones who showed up
there without a reservation Along Came
Don Creek who let the largest Fleet in
the entire East blue because after after
dracul mihawk has sliced up his Fleet
and ships in the grand line he then
tried to take the baraz for himself
however despite his underhanded tactics
of using poison spikes Cannon and much
much more he couldn't compare with
Luffy's brute strength and was
completely wiped out and with d Creek
also defeated there was now only one
pirate left in the entire East blue who
was more powerful and Infamous which was
Arlon now this saw shark Fishman gave
Luffy his most difficult fight in the
story yet but the stakes were pretty
personal at this point the final fight
actually ended in the map room where
arlong had tortured Nami for years
forcing her to draw Maps since her
childhood and so to make up for it Luffy
brought on arlong and his entire park
with a gumgum axe which means that we're
now entering the grand line and Luffy
wouldn't take another win until little
garden where he went up against the
candleman Mr 3 whose real name is
actually galdino it turns out now most
of the crew was nearly turned into a wax
museum but Luffy waxed on and waxed off
until galdino was well G decimated sorry
for that one on drum Island then Luffy
dethroned wle a cruel king with a bad
case of the munchies and this was
actually the first Monarch or King that
Luffy would ever punch but it certainly
wouldn't be the last one and in doing so
he turned the drum Kingdom into a
democracy when Dalton was then elected
the leader of the newly dued Sakura
Kingdom in retrospect Luffy being a very
American in that Arc I guess and then
Luffy went from beating his first king
to his first warlord when Luffy defeated
sir crocodile in round three of their
fight after being defeated twice by the
sand user Luffy beat him up using
nothing but his own Blood Sweat and
Tears but mostly his blood I guess which
hardened the loia user sand and allowed
him to be battered right through the
ceiling of the Tomb of the kings in the
palace and the crew's next destination
after that was jaia well Luffy was able
to demonstrate just how much he had
grown to resemble his mentor Shanks
because when this guy Bellamy here
picked a fight and made fun of Luffy's
dreams but he just sat there and took it
just like Shanks did because he really
wasn't worth the trouble but later when
Bellamy actually dared to hurt one of
Luffy's friends then Luffy got very
serious and so the spring devil fruit
user bounced all around G but Luffy
himself didn't even need to use his
devil fruit at all all it took was a
single punch to break balam's Spirit
completely and then later once Luffy and
Co found themselves on the sky island of
skypia well they went up against nl's
priests Luffy actually did help out
Sanji against this guy here called
Satori but Sanji made the finishing blow
here and Luffy's real battle after all
on the island was against God himself or
or at least someone who considered
himself to be a God in fact NL here had
never met an opponent who wasn't
instantly incinerated by his lightning
strikes but was in for a very big
surprise when Luffy's rubber body was
just completely immune to any of his
attacks and so surprisingly even without
his lightning powers enel still put up a
quite decent fight using his observation
hockey which he called Mantra however in
the end Luffy defeated him and rang the
bell of the city of gold which brings us
to the next opponent back on the blue
sea on the infamous long ring longland
when Foxy the Silver Fox challenged the
straw hats to a Davy back fight and in
the final round of the game these two
captains had a one-on-one matchup
however Foxy's slow beam was so hard to
deal with that it took Luffy's ultimate
form to defeat him which is afro Luffy
and so despite Foxy's tricks and traps
nothing could defeat the boxing powers
of AFR Luffy and he did up ending
winning this round and also ending maybe
the most tedious Arc in all of One Piece
and surprisingly the next opponent was
even more difficult for Luffy to fight
than the near Invincible foxy however
this one wasn't physically difficult it
was emotionally very taxing that's
because on water 7 Usopp challenged
Luffy for the ownership of the going
marry the cruise ship that needed to be
replaced and suffered extreme damage
during their adventures and so usub used
all of the resources and knowledge he
had gained about Luffy's weaknesses
throughout all their adventures together
but ultimately still was completely
outclassed by his Captain's true
strength and then when the crew finally
stormed in his Lobby to save Robin
Luffy's first victim was the cp9 agent
Bruno who ate the door door fruit
however even for someone who can make
their doors anywhere there was no Escape
from the insane speed of Luffy's new
power gear seconds and the fight against
bluno was oda's way of showing off the
new strength of Luffy's New Gear
techniques before Luffy then fought the
real opponent of this Arc the leader of
cp9 and the leopard fruit user Rob Luchi
because this leopard Zone fruit user
gave Luffy his toughest fight in the
entire story so far this cp9 Powerhouse
was willing to carry out any order on
behalf of the government all to satisfy
his own immense blood lust and Luchi
actually started by devastating Luffy
with the secret techniques called the
six Powers which don't actually show up
all that much in one piece and
particularly his strongest attack the
uan however Luchi finally met defeat on
the receiving end of Luffy's jet Gatling
gun as well and before leaving water 7
Luffy's grandfather showed up to crash
the party leading to a quick rematch
with Kobe and as anyone would have
predicted Kobe did not stand a chance at
all but he sure is getting stronger
though throughout the story meanwhile
Luffy's next terrifying opponent was on
the horror themed island of Thrilla bark
here the warlord geeko Modia resurrected
his ultimate zombie orse from the body
of a fearsome ancient Giant and things
looked pretty bleak for the straw hats
but Luffy took in a ton of Shadows into
his own body in order to transform into
Nightmare Luffy one of his most iconic
and unique forms and ended up crushing
orse and as a result next up was Modia
himself the next warlord on the list to
fall to Luffy and even when Modia used
Shadow's Asgard to suck 1,000 Shadows
into himself and boost his own strength
he still was not able to defeat Luffy
and so with every punch that Luffy
landed Moria spit out more Shadows
unable to control the power of so many
at once and after that fight nothing
really happened on thrill bark anymore
if you get my drift and right after when
the crew then arrived at sabba ODI
archipelago well they were to tackle the
new world unfortunately those plans went
completely sideways when they went to
rescue their mermaid friend Cy from a
slave auction and so when the Celestial
Dragon s Charlos shoots Haan one of
Luffy's friends Luffy does the morally
correct thing that anyone should do when
encountering someone who owns slaves and
you know punch them into Oblivion and
then after Kuma here gives lufan all
expenses paid trip to Amazon Lily he
finds himself in trial by combat against
a black panther but as the real king of
the jungle Luffy showed bakura the
panther who is the boss but that wasn't
over yet because after that BOA hanok
sisters Mari gold and S Sonia here went
up against Luffy as well and and let's
be real Luffy would definitely have
taken the wble here but the match was
later called off when Luffy went out of
his way to hide the mark of the
celestial dragons on the Gorgon sister's
Backs from The Other Women of Amazon
Lily thus stealing boa Hancock's heart
for life which now brings us to the
entirety of the mar Mar Fort Saga well
Luffy was just way out of his element
yes he took out a lot of f impal down in
Marine Fort but in the end failed to
take out even a single big opponent so
yeah Luffy was truly in his big L era
right here however the ever Dependable
Kobe was there as always to be taken
down by Luffy in one hit giving him that
one W that he really needed and I guess
technically if you wanted to Luffy did
also knock out his own grandfather GARP
the hero of the Marines I mean GARP
didn't fight back whatsoever but still
he did knock him down on the way to the
Executioner stance of maybe like half a
point here and then after taking a
couple of years off to power up Luffy
was back in business when he returned to
sabba Odi archipelago and took out the
piif fista that used to give him trouble
like they were nothing and then while
descending to Fishman Island Luffy
befriended a giant Kraken the only way
he knows how to make friends by punching
it as hard as he possibly could however
we have to say he wasn't really trying
to make any friends when he punched hodi
Jones here the leader of the new Fishman
Pirates again as hard as he could and
even though hod Jones himself was a bit
of a disappointment as a villain the
battle against him really just served to
prove how much stronger Luffy and the
other straw hats had become over the
time Skip and I mean we have to consider
here that his opponent was powered up by
an insane amount of energy steroids he
was fighting a Fishman while underwater
even though he is a devil fruit user and
even with all of these massive handicaps
Luffy took him out and destroyed this
giant Arc here the Noah with his Red
Hawk and elephant gun techniques like
flexing by using a Firepower at the
bottom of the ocean but moving on the
straw Hat's next destination was Punk
Hazard where Luffy lost the first round
to CES a clown who deprived him of
oxygen using his devil fruit Powers
however then very quickly in round two
of this fight Luffy figures out Caesar's
trick and learns to keep the necessary
distance that he has to stay away in
order to keep being able to breathe and
so Luffy once again clowns on another
clown with his awesome Grizzly Magnum
technique that we see there for the very
first time and right after Punk Hazard
Luffy partnered up with Trafalga law and
the Allies went to take down doflamingo
another warlord well actually they went
to destroy the smile Factory so that
kaido would take down doflamingo but I
mean we all know how well Luffy can
follow a plan not at all so instead Oda
brought us to a gladiator match where a
suspiciously familiar contestant named
Lucy fought to try to get the Mira
miromi that once belonged to Ace and at
that Coliseum Lucy who was shockingly
revealed to be Luffy in Disguise all
along easily brought down the giant
hydogen who then would go on to join his
Grand Fleet he also fought this old
pirate named Don chin jaao who was once
a rival of Luffy's grandfather GARP and
despite Luffy having really nothing to
do with that old conflict whatsoever
ever chinia held a grudge and wanted to
take it out on garp's grandson I guess
and that actually gave Luffy a chance to
practice his conqueror hockey and with a
powerful hockey punch he gave Don
chinjao his pointy head back that he had
missed so much but of course right after
chinjao there came the first real test
of Luffy's new Strength ever since the
time skip because let's be real everyone
that Luffy had to fight up to this point
he never really had to give it his all
but doflamingo really pushed Luffy to
his limits here forcing him to reveal
his now ultimate technique at this point
gear forth that's because Bas Luffy
couldn't keep up with the flamingo's
crazy strength and speed but once he
transformed into gear fourth bounceman
he wiped the smile off of D flamingo's
face and defeated the Celestial Dragon
and thus ended his terrible Reign Over
dress Rosa but then right after dress
Rosa the crew set their eyes on the fort
empress and in order to save Sanji Luffy
invaded big mom's territory of hake
islands and in order to get his cookb
Luffy had to take down not one but two
of her sweet commanders and first was
cracker the warrior who had fought with
hardened biscuit soldiers unfortunately
for him cracker couldn't make enough
biscuits to deal with Luffy's Grand
appetite and so after eating his fill
Luffy used those extra calories to turn
into tankman and cracker got cooked
right after though Luffy's hardest fight
yet came in the form of katak Curry the
future side master who could predict his
every move and one of my all-time
favorite antagonists that Luffy ever
fought now katakuri stretchy Moji fruit
gave him the mirror image of Luffy's own
powers just stronger which was very
fitting since their fight took place in
the mirror world and over the course of
their long battle Luffy developed his
observation hockey allowing him to see
briefly into the future and the battle
basically ended in a draw with both
Fighters seemingly down for the count
but Luffy was able to get back up and
Escape hul island with his crew mates
though there is a lot of discussion
whether could Curry just let him win in
the end or not which brings us to wano
where in its First Act Luffy's first
opponent was the Sumo champion urashima
and despite urashima Superior weight
class I guess he was still no match for
Luffy next up this lion bellied gifter
on kaido's crew was also completely
outclassed by Luffy who defeated him
with a red hawk attack reminding otama
of Luffy's brother Ace now of course
none of these battles on wano really
required Luffy to go all out at this
point except well the one person you all
been waiting for which is of course
kaido Emperor and the world's strongest
creature who gave Luffy the hardest
fight of his life kaido's draconic
transformation and command of advanced
conqueror hockey and future side made
this Emperor more powerful than anyone
Luffy had fought at this point in the
story in fact kaido was so strong that
he defeated Luffy twice at least and
then seemingly literally killed him
after the last one unfortunately for
kaido that all Al led to Luffy Awakening
his devil fruit and after that gear five
Luffy went completely Looney Tunes on
him using Dragon form kaido as a jump
rope and sending the king of the Beast
to the Magmar depths beneath Mount Fuji
and with this battle Luffy truly became
Joy boy successor and earned himself a
title as one of the four Emperors of the
sea himself and then right after the
land of the Samurai the crew headed to
egad Island where they reunited with
some old Rivals Rob Luchi and Kaku who
had been promoted to zp0 now honestly
these guys seem to fail upwards almost
as much as buggy here and even though
Ruchi had also awakened his Zone fruit
at this point just like Luffy he just
couldn't keep up with the absolutely
wild abilities of gear five and was at a
disadvantage when Stussy ended the fight
by putting Luchi to sleep kind of
stealing the fight from Luffy actually
but anyways a much more suitable
opponent for gear five Luffy was the
Admiral who showed up after cp0 kizaru
who had demolished the crew alongside
Kuma 2 years prior at sabba ODI
archipelago however now gear five Luffy
can actually fight the light fruit user
on roughly equal footing and the match
ended essentially in a draw with both
Fighters completely immobilized but
after this insane streak of wins
throughout the story and this match
being a tie what about all the matches
that Luffy straight up lost I mean most
of the time through Shia willpower Luffy
is able to pull ahead and beat car
character is many many times stronger
than himself however on surprisingly
many occasions throughout one piece he
has been fully and utterly defeated how
many times you ask and by who well you
can find out exactly when and how Luffy
has been defeated throughout the entire
Series in this video right here shks for
watching and I will see you in this next
one